well sarah you know what was it about
firefly lane that you adored and made
you want to be a part of it
oh i i couldn't believe it when i was
reading it's one of those times where
you're reading a script went oh my god
oh it's so good oh and it gets better
and i cried i felt all of the feelings
and i just
overall loved that it was this strong
story about two women
um and their incredible friendship i
related to it so much
i related to their best friendship i'm
lucky enough to have a tully in my life
who has been there for me every day and
and then i just loved i fell in love
with this character and
how she grew over the series and went
from being so vulnerable and awkward and
shy
and just trying to please everyone else
to really making
bold and strong choices for herself and
um
yeah there was a lot of a lot of uh
getting outside of my comfort zone
um in terms of singing and and
and giving birth and um very little
clothing
so you always look for those kind of
challenges in a part and this was one of
those
things that kind of had everything it
had the storyline and the role
and then the chance to work with katie
um which we just had the best time so
kind of get everything this friendship
on screen you don't see this sort of
friendship on screen that often
just opposite to track it's realistic
it's beautiful it's kind of like the
love story
of the series for me um catherine for
you you know would you say that
opposites attract in this
um i think in this yes i think that
if you know if kate were had the same
kind of
ambition and um all of that that tully
is
i think they would clash you know i
don't think that it would be
competitive versus loving and
um but i think that their their
attraction to each other is more just
about well for tully i think it's it's
more about that she just can sense
instantly as a 14 year old girl
upon meeting kate for the first time
that this is a
very good person buddy
that she can trust and count on um
and there isn't any of that sort of
sticky kind of mean
girl middle school thing yeah and it's
she's just an open book and an open
heart and it's just what tully needs
with such an unstable and tumultuous
family life
yeah one of my favorite moments of this
is you guys exploring your midlife
sexual adventures
so what was it like filming those scenes
for both of you catherine we can start
with you
lord um this is the most that i've ever
done that
like sex scene wise i've never done this
much
yeah like been exposed this much and i
remember
um our the director of our second block
ann wheeler uh
sort of she sold me this really and it
was a female director so i felt
safe with her but she told me this she's
like i want to do this shot where it's
just your full naked back
like sitting on a counter
you know having sex with max's character
and
um you know it'll be a really wide shot
it'll be really beautiful and blah blah
and i was like well
you're 40 well at the time i was 41 i
was like
all right man
[Laughter]
you made it sound so beautiful and sexy
and i would like to believe
that i can look beautiful and sexy at
41. yes
please make it a wide angle lens
and um please be really far back there
and uh please you know let me see it
before you
put it in but that was like i have never
been so naked on a set before that was
really
weird i'm like
you did it and you killed it can i even
say that you killed it
good job thank you so much for saying
that thank you
sarah what about you yeah i mean it's
you know there wasn't any actual sort of
full
nudity for kate but there's lots of
times where you're filming something
where you're still in front of a hundred
crew members and you're wearing
extremely little clothing sometimes
involving stickers
so um it you definitely feel
like okay here we go and like katie i
was like well if not now then when i
mean this is
we're pushing the limit here and um
obviously i did a lot of
you know broad underwear stuff and
scrubs but i was
20 something and um so
it definitely felt like we were we were
stretching ourselves and getting outside
of our comfort zones and we would always
um you know run things by each other and
we got to be very involved in the
choosing of said underwear which was
great
um you had your whole diving into the
pool naked thing
that is true in the winter in canada um
so that was that was definitely a um
hypothermia i
i did have blue lips not a lot of
clothing and
blue lips um uh yes my
any time i get freezing my my lips will
be but it was it was
it was absolutely uh part of the
challenge right
getting out of that getting out of the
comfort zone
you